pense que n'importe quoi personne n'y
avait pensé soissons le défi est un peu
fou mais pour le papa en question jean
jacques largeron c'est la passion qui
les a menés de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
sa femme stéphanie et leurs trois
enfants esteban jay and he et lan sont
aussi des mordus du basket pendant plus
de six mois ils s'aventureront aux états
unis ainsi qu'à toronto pour voir leurs
joueurs préférés à l'oeuvre oui c'est un
enfant indéniable mais je le fais aussi
pour mes enfants
alors il en est encore un peu petit mais
pour esteban et gm comme je le dis je me
demande bien souvent s'ils se rendent
compte de la chance qu'ils ont de vivre
une aventure une expérience pareille
l'idée du voyage est venue lors d'un
séjour à new york en novembre 2007 alors
que le petit dernier et l'amener avec un
an a été un peu le déclic c'est ça a été
en effet de voir toutes les étoiles qui
pouvait y avoir dans les yeux de mes
enfants lors de lors d'un match nba dans
une salle heures telles que le madison
square garden qui plus est la famille a
décidé de partager son aventure sur les
médias sociaux et l'a rapidement gagnant
en popularité
leur compte instagram est suivi par près
de 8000 abonnés
leur histoire a résonné aux quatre coins
de la nba qui leur a donné l'opportunité
de faire encore plus de rencontres donc
par exemple chez les raptors on a eu la
possibilité d'aller carrément sur le
terrain de parler avec des joueurs chose
qu'on avait pas encore fait jusqu'à
présent en tout cas dans l'est dans les
salles et je pense que là ils commencent
à avoir ce déclic à se dire waouh
ce qu'on fait c'est
et on va pas simplement un mage la
famille voyage à bord d'une caravane
motorisée la mission c'est d'éviter les
autoroutes pour admirer les paysages se
sont en quelque sorte de grandes
vacances
on pousse beaucoup la question et
l'école et l'école et l'école c'est une
question qui revient souvent de la part
des réserves donné et on essaye dit on
essaie d'y répondre
c'est vrai que c'est important mais mais
il ya tout ce qui est autour aussi qui
qui l'est encore plus on les a toujours
eu très très très très serré et voilà
c'est de voir cette petite bouille
souriante
c'est le plus beau cadeau que l'on peut
pas on peut avoir coincé ici raphaël
guilmette radio canada toronto